hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com so in this video i would like
to talk about the bitcoin because it's a
very hot topic in the past week so i'm
gonna try to sum up a bit the situation
explain to you guys why to me the
bitcoin uh has went
uh has gone that high and what might
potentially happen
in the near future and for red reasons
let's get into it
[Music]
alright so start on the weekly time
frame so very quickly guys i would like
to show you again
how i did to find that 35 000 would be
a resistance level all right so i used
fib extensions
i measure the last wave that is like
here
and i applied this to this uh level
around here all right
so this is this is like basically
showing me you know the growth
of this wave should be a golden ratio
of this wave all right so the golden
ratio
is 1.618 and you can find this pretty
much
everywhere in the world in everything
that is growing and it's not only this
it's something that is followed by
a lot of big investors big institutional
clients
because they're using this technique
that is working as you can see guys
if i go on the daily time frame uh
the 35 000 levels i did a video last
week on this
and it was on sunday and so basically
the bitcoin was here guys
you know it was on the 3rd of january
and the next day
what happened all right just after we
reached 35 000 for the first time
we got a massive correction of 20
in one day all right so guys you know
this is not uh something that just
happened uh like this
this is because a lot of people are
following this technique
and they used 25 000 and they found that
35 000 is gonna be level we're going to
have a lot of selling pressure and this
is what happened
then i said that basically we're going
to consolidate for the next
week you know maybe two three weeks uh
around
35 000 so this is what is happening here
right we are here so 35 35000 is the
pivot point and we are just going around
it
here here here all right and i think
that this might
continue for a little while very quickly
before i'm telling you guys what i would
do in this situation the way i would
trade it
i would like just to explain to you the
difference uh between this rally that
we're having right now
and the rally that we had uh three years
ago you have this website
etf trends that is very interesting you
have a lot of stuff on the economy
and they did an article uh here
where they basically explained that a
lot of institutional clients like paul
jones who is a hedge fund manager
for like 20 30 years and that he uh
basically is using the bitcoin as a
hedge against
inflation so this guy basically um
you know buys some bitcoin so he bought
he bought around 400 million us dollar
last month so it's like you know around
five percent of his like uh
a um asset under management uh because
of all the money printing that we had
since
uh march uh crisis you know the fed has
printed around three trillion dollars so
three thousand billion dollars uh in uh
stimulus packages
and they will also lower taxes you know
some fiscal stimulus as well you know
especially that now we have the
democrats at the congress
uh in the senate uh they're gonna vote
probably
some more um you know easing measures
so you know all this so they're
basically uh giving money away to
everyone that's what they do
and this is basically creating inflation
and that's the purpose of it all right
uh so inflation is just weakening the
dollar that's why
we have a weak dollar and i was
explaining this in my other videos as
well
if this continues uh all the hedge fund
managers that i invested in dollars they
could just lose some money
so they like to hedge their positions
and all these guys who have pulled you
the drones
you have mass mutuals uh which is like
hedge funds
the chief investment officer of good
name investment you know scott minard
and this guy he's
you know managing 233 billion us dollars
all right so it's a lot of money
and all these guys they've been buying
the bitcoin here all right
and they created this rally so now you
know
now once you know where the floors are
coming from you can make a better
analysis of what could happen next
so let me just remind you something the
way these guys invest their money
all right we are in january generally
you need to propose a new uh investment
strategy you know to
create some return and to attract some
new investors in your hedge fund all
right
or in your company so um
they decided to talk about the bitcoin
and to use it as a hedge
but maybe they are done with this hedge
you know they're not gonna buy every
month or maybe they would i'm not sure
but to me you know they're gonna do it
once
maybe even gonna try to take profits
maybe they they were selling here i
don't know
so what i'm just saying is that once
these guys that would be down
who is gonna buy the bitcoin here retail
investors i don't think so
all right i think that retail investors
are already full of bitcoin and they're
thinking where they could sell it
so maybe they're not gonna sell right
now but trust me that a lot of them
are actually considering to sell a bid
or maybe
all of their position so uh now very
quickly
how i would play this so i do a sloping
trend line that is here you know so i
just connect you know on the shoulder
time frame
i connect uh the lows that i have here
one
two three four and here five
all right but i was saying for those who
are following me on instagram
trading sensors uh where i post
basically some daily updates on the
markets and some news i was saying that
here
be careful guys we have a support level
if it's broken it can
get really dirty all right bloody
and it has been broken but not confirmed
you can see that this candle has closed
finally above this level
and i have a friend that was actually
calling me yesterday he knows
uh i'm talking about him i'm not gonna
give his name
he has a lot of bitcoin and he was
telling me uh
man bro uh what would you do in my
situation and and i told him i wouldn't
uh he wanted to
to put a stop loss here he didn't
indiana to me it was not a good idea
because
it's full of bear traps this market is
very wide so it's not a good market to
put stop losses so you can
a trade that you could do you can buy
here put a stop loss here all right
around you know 10 lower so basically
around you buy at 32
33 you sell at 39 all right
and you can play the next uh resistance
level at 55 000 all right that is here
this one here 55 is the next one guys so
maybe we're going
there i don't know you can play this
trade otherwise you can just
try to you know sell a bit of your
position
you can see that here we are
consolidating all right usually when we
have this kind of consolidation
the market likes to revert all right and
then maybe go to the 20 000
level where you have a lot of
institution clients that maybe haven't
bought the position yet
i don't know if you want to exit a bit
of your position you just you know take
the high here the
low here uh of the last move which was
like minus 25
guys what happened that happened uh
yesterday and you just
sell at the feed retracements all right
so 30 38.2 50 61.8
so it's like 20 34 500 335
900 and 337 200 all right those three
levels you're gonna find a lot of
selling pressure
here okay you can see once we had it
second time we had it we're probably
gonna have it tomorrow
and the day after tomorrow again so if
you want to exit your position i would
advise to
um i mean what i would do i don't give
her advices
but what i would do is that i would sell
it here all right otherwise we can play
the the move up and if
we break it and we confirm it on the
daily time frame guys i did a video of
the on the breakout to go check it out
if you haven't
where i explain how to trade breakouts
and especially on the bitcoin you need
to be on the daily time frame
uh and you need to wait for a
confirmation all right so
one candle closes below the second
candle trades below all right this is a
confirmation
then probably we're gonna have some more
move
down all right so i hope i managed to
make myself clear
i hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please click
the like sub and bell button so you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys